it's hard work for all parties when I'm
so proud of them promoting that and
hopefully you know inspiring other
people the Kardashians could write a
complete how-to guide on how to be
friends with your ex and they proved it
again
on Father's Day I love it Exhibit A
Kourtney Kardashian hit up Instagram to
give mad love to her ex Scott Disick
Kourt shared this snap of her and Scott
with their three kiddos Mason Penelope
and rain writing happy Father's Day
thankful for you and these three special
ones cute right
it was definitely a process just to
recap Kourt and Scott called it quits in
2015 after almost a decade of dating
then Scott dated Sophia Richie for about
three years but they split in May so
when the 41 year old reality star was
spotted wearing her ex's flannel shirt
on a recent family vacay to Wyoming fans
speculated that the two were back
together and while their current
relationship status is unclear back in
2019 scott told ET the secret to
co-parenting like a boss i think you
just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
you just want to be happy you want to be
content you want to be comfortable life
is a challenge and if you work out what
you want you can get it but it takes
hard work simple as that you can easily
live less of a life without working as
hard and that's a peace moving right
along to Exhibit B Khloe Kardashian who
gave a special shout out to her ex
Tristan Thompson Coco shared several
pics of the NBA star with their
two-year-old daughter true writing happy
Father's Day you two are definitely
twins just a little refresher the two
split in February 2019
candle with Kylie Jenner's former bestie
Jordan woods you know things have been
and of course I'm sorry but now Khloe
and Tristan seem to be super focused on
co-parenting their baby girl everyone
has to handle their co-parenting
situation in their own style but it's a
beautiful thing to get along with each
other and for your kids to see that and
a source told et last month that the two
have bonded while quarantine together
quote this
alone time has really allowed them to
reconnect without outside influences I'm
just super happy and content and I'm
focused on work and like taking care of
me my body and soul and true on Sunday
Chloe also shared several throwback pics
of her former stepdad Caitlyn Jenner on
her instace Tori Chloe's insta post
seems to suggest she and Caitlyn have
worked out their differences back in a
November episode of the British reality
series I'm a celebrity get me out of
here
Caitlin claimed she hadn't really spoken
with Chloe in five or six years Chloe
and I were really close
I raised Chloe since she was five years
old Chloe for some reason was pissed off
about something through this whole
process honestly it's been five six
years and I really haven't talked to her
since Chloe also shared this shot of
Caitlyn formerly Bruce posing with her
late dad Robert Kardashian and last year
Chloe
opened up to et about how her mom Kris
Jenner dad and stepdad set the standard
for being friends with your ex it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and so we come
from a family where we believe in that
and you shared children with people and
that's how it should be